I believe that again as a child every
single one of these articles played an
important role a destructive role uh in
my growing up
to give any confirmation that I can
specifically remember reading the
Articles at the time I believe would be
speculation
yes as you said more than thousands
maybe millions of Articles have been
written about me since age 12.
yes because again because it's 20 years
ago I simply cannot speculate how it was
and whether I saw these articles at the
time I certainly saw lots of Articles at
the time unfortunately stories that
you've only that I've only shared with
one or two people within my inner circle
ends up front page of newspaper or any
page your circle of friends starts to
shrink and
diminish rather rapidly